alexis comment vous avez trouvé
aujourd'hui c'est le pôle télé johnny
qu'on connaît ouais il ya eu beaucoup de
séquences ouais c'est très long oui
enchère série y compris moi la séquence
avec la séquence des mots la séquence
est qu'ils ont été plus long que ce qui
était prévu oui il a des moments sans
doute que les thèmes sa tournée un peu
vont très bien après sur les retraites
mais il ya eu des moments forts il ya eu
des choses je dire qu'ils ont lieu des
choses qui fonctionnent plus ou moins
moi je lave ou je trouvais que aymeric
caron qui vient expliquer pour quelles
raisons alors qu'ils ne soutenaient pas
jean-luc mélenchon la dernière fois sur
la question animale bien c'était
intéressant sabrina ali benali qui est
médecin est formé de montreuil est
vraiment une fille formidable je trouve
qu'elle a dit des choses très fortes et
mènera le conseil s'était très bien
passé il ya eu des clashs et parmi eux
mêmes y compris là on voit bien on a
deux champions bon xbox catholique je
vous dis bon c'est ça non mais je verse
et des idées de projets de société deux
visions de la france on est dans une
émission en plus où c'est le format de
l'émission cher cyril hanouna oui je
veux dire c'est aussi en format où les
idées se frottent et ça fait de
l'audience moi ce que je souhaite
surtout c'est que les gens aillent voter
au mois d'avril que l'on écouté les
débats faites vous une idée il ya les
meetings et les émissions le meeting
c'est un format il ya des bouquins on
prend le temps il ya des émissions comme
la vôtre je ne dis pas de manière
méprisante parce que j'ai déjà salué ça
c'est un autre format que ce qui peut
exister sur le service public c'est plus
populaire c'est plus enlevée c'est plus
séquencée ok mais ailleurs si les tueurs
ont bondi sur ce que vous dites moi je
le dis je pense que les deux des deux
émissions sont complémentaires les
missions du service public est très bien
sûr voilà c'est un autre format celle ci
est très bien non mais j'ai entendu à
pauline de malherbe mon ex amie ce matin
sur
tu peux quoi sur quoi les d'ailleurs
cet agent réviser mes émissions qu'à
dire qu'ils étaient trop bruyant a pas
pauline en fait l'émission si hier on
fait un tel score sur les 25 49 il faut
qu'ils aient du show s'il n'y a pas de
show dans l'émission vous allez vous
retrouver avec tendance à regarder
insisté m comme a dit alexis si ça peut
aider les jeunes à aller voter il est
jeune à regarder un show voilà donc ça
va dégoûter surtout les gens allaient de
aller voter on perd les jeunes ce cas on
voit bon sens en passant par l'attaqué
du chu merkel et moi on en parlera après
s'est fait pas partie de la casse de
injuste tout de suite les gendarmes qui
mêlera morel juste juste un mot comme
sur la forme hier parce que ça m'a
beaucoup choqué de la forme de la part
de jean luc mélenchon qui toute la
soirée a été d'un mépris toute la soirée
c'était à la nuit je suis contre une
bonne question à laon valoir pas et vous
massa quand on veut tous les éléments
pour le voit des gens pètent président a
une vocation on le voit
dans ce pays râles des bises à israël
des frontières et personne à la vie
qu'on n'existe plus du tout ya peu
frontières orale est d'accord d'accord
eh ben je parle comme je ne valais pas
comme ça alors oui ok mélenchon est
comment dire ça
alors actuellement s'il est ce que c'est
vrai aujourd'hui qu'il ya des visas des
frontières mais
le sujet
lui commandait agacé vous êtes sont bien
des visages à la niche mais j'attends
que le froid ni soumises me laisse la
parole comme d'habitude
je désire vais attendre et que je ne
voulais intégrer ça je désire avant tout
je vous avais dit que je ne débattrai
avec raquel garrido j'ai appris qu'elle
était souffrante donc 1 j'espère que
c'est pas grave évidemment c'est rigolo
embrassera et de the tree alexis
corbière de lui transmettre mes voeux de
prompt rétablissement
alors maintenant sur le débat d'hier il
s'agit pas d'être convaincus ou pas
convaincu moi j'ai eu la confirmation
d'une immense déception jean luc
mélenchon a été dans un passé déjà
ancien quelqu'un pour lequel j'avais de
l'estimé politiques notamment parce que
nous partagions les mêmes principes
républicains il a décidé la france a
soumises a décidé de brader de troquer
tous ces principes républicains contre
des votes communautaire que les sondages
actuels nous cordes même pas c'est donc
j'ai appris je termine je vous ai pas
interrompu
j'ai appris que ça ne dérangeait pas les
poupées sans visage de roubaix ne
dérangeait pas monsieur mélenchon moi je
préfère les femmes avec visage parce que
les femmes avec 10 h c'est le visage de
la france les femmes sans visage c'est
le visage de l'obscurantisme islamiste
j'ai aussi appris en écoutant de cheveux
mélenchon qu'il était beaucoup plus
aimable envers les islamistes qu'envers
les policiers qu'il a traitée avec un
mépris qu'on n'avait jamais vu entendu
justement de la part d'un responsable
éthique voire sept experts s'est excusé
fait énormément parler nous regarde le
ciel c'est ça il nous obéir est comme
les autres vous et n'oubliez pas ce que
je veux moi je suis république avec
javier plus de n'a pu créer des clans
drôme en plus de flash ball plus
grenades de désencerclement y en a fait
jusqu'à retourner de la cave au grenier
est dit et il serait plus policier si je
suis élu et vous donnez de l'intérieur
et le seront mais bon qui vous prenez
vous
je termine on a vu pendant toute la
soirée un discours anti républicain
monsieur mélenchon ne se contente plus
de vouloir désarmer la police maintenant
ils méprisent la police il insulte à
moitié des policiers qui font un travail
admirable je regrette il n'y a pas que
des policiers vertueux mais sans les
policiers on serait mal y a que deux
solutions monsieur corbières ou pouvoir
dans les banlieues et dans les quartiers
difficiles est à la police soit l'état
voyou il faut choisir vous avez choisi
les islamistes si vous avez choisi les
voyous vous aurez la défaite et vous
aurez le déshonneur et je suis très
inquiet de la trace laissera monsieur
mélenchon dans l'histoire il aurait pu
laisser une trace glorieux à l'avant si
maintenant s'il était resté fidèle à ses
principes républicains vous avez décidé
de les brader vous avez décidé de les
vendre à l'encan l'histoire sera très
sévère avec vous une arabo musulman avec
jean luc mélenchon et les complices si
je vous gérez vous dire la vie bruno
pomart doivent appeler mon twitter que
vous votez zemmour vous contrôlez votre
zemmour
et
le gigot élevé moore je ne me permets de
préciser votre ventre et j'ai dit entre
zemmour et mélenchon ou redescendre
quelqu'un qui accepte la contradiction
comme c'est à dire qu'ils acceptent 0
lato et mélenchon qui pose pour
condition de seulement 2 voilà ma
conception de la démocratie est
davantage sur ce point précis auprès de
défendre
gerland pendant deux ans vous m'avez
traité de ma chronique maintenant vous
me traitez de zemmourien les deux ne
sont pas possible ils sont adversaires
les nationaux l'eau donc trouver au bout
mais on n'est pas là dedans c'est dans
les
majeures à calgary douanes au pouvoir ex
patrons du rail à la face à la facilité
de d'alexis corps bien c'est de
détourner le sujet mais sa sévérité des
politiques évidemment road eu beaucoup
de politiques a pas qu'eux mais à un
coût quoi qu'il en soit concernant
monsieur mélenchon at il convaincu il a
convaincu les 250000 forces de l'ordre
qualité vraiment anti flics car on voit
de la façon dont il a traité ce
brigadier-chef que je connais qui est un
vrai professionnel c'est une honte quand
il l'a accueilli en lui disant vous avez
votre ciseaux mais un c'est pas le
niveau d'un présidentiable sitter c'est
un anti républicain c'est un malotru mal
élevés mathieu d'éducation moi qui suis
un élu du rural vous savez je respecte
beaucoup plus les élus d'opposition que
le fait monsieur mélenchon avec ses
interlocuteurs au même titre que
d'ailleurs que je suis pas partisan de
zemmour loin de là mais je trouve qu'il
a été aussi pareil avec zemmour avec ce
policier c'est pathétique c'est
pathétique parce que la police a
tellement besoin de soutien des
politiques et vous et vos compatriotes
vous êtes en train d'essayer de créer un
séparatisme vous et je vais vous dire
pourquoi monsieur monsieur pour bien
puisque vous êtes vous allez peut-être
pas souvent à un quartier moi ce soir je
suis sonné sous voir au sol avec 300
jeunes non mais je veux dire c'est de
travailler le rapprochement des jeunes
et la police et vous voir ce que vous
faites toute la journée si vous essayez
de séparer de secondaire 2 d'apporter la
haine sur la police est parce que
effectivement ça vous permet de récolter
évidemment pour être député il va
falloir avoir séduit pour sa population
pour renouveler vos mandats de député
c'est tout ce qui les intéresse donc
tout est bon il a raison qu'est ce que
je ferais mais comme tous les autres
vous fait pas beaucoup de terrain mais
vous faites beaucoup de lobbying au
moment des élections
pour attirer votre propulsion ratifie
que c'est à dire les 5 6% de la
population qui n'aime pas les filles pas
précis me fait rire pas 5 6% mais bien
sûr de son fait et rien du tout mais
vous étiez lurex axé pour l'essentiel
pour monsieur mélenchon comme pour vous
offrir des récents plaît s'il vous plaît
champ